handin ever since the breakup was
official
dude the floodgates have been open now
few [ __ ] loose ass women did and
you're like his heart is broken I could
heal it with this [ __ ] you know what
though that was one of the things that
what that was a pick-up line from women
really it was like not not exactly but
not not what you said okay [ __ ] this and
feel better yeah but it was it was
straight up like if you need someone to
talk to you know yeah yeah that kind of
[ __ ] and at first my low self-esteem ass
would just really talk to them and be
like yeah so this is what you know thank
you for your time and then it's like oh
wait thank you for your time
oh wait they actually want it bored yeah
okay well are we are we gonna [ __ ] her
or not it's like well I thought you said
you're just gonna listen to me already
like ya know I mean it was crazy like
just I realized that being in a toxic
relationship and it wasn't just toxic
for me was toxic for Jess to the the
thing was we we really [ __ ] each
other's self-esteem in the past couple
of years like we really made each other
feel small and I think if I can go back
and do it over again I wish I never
[ __ ] her [ __ ] self-esteem up like
that because I realize now how bad that
was cuz I was unaware like it's like
smoking a cigarette like every single
day you smoked one and then before you
know it you got [ __ ] emphysema or
some [ __ ] right yeah it's a slow killer
so over the years you're chipping away
at each other's self worth confidence
whatever it is and you're unaware that
you've been all [ __ ] up yeah so one of
the things that was like you know like
basically I was told I suck at kissing
right and then I mean it was said on JK
news before it's not like a secret or
whatever but I was told that so II
though it might be true to her in my
head I thought that was true to
everybody yeah that was it I was like I
suck at kissing I'm not I'm unromantic
whatever I can't I can't but what ended
up happening was I [ __ ] kissed all
damn night
yeah and ain't nobody make no [ __ ]
complaints I yeah she and in fact they
enjoyed it yeah the [ __ ] and yeah and it
was like the the energy was great they
wanted more and more and so in my head
I'm like man this is [ __ ] crazy wait
was that was that was the kissing issue
that you had with Jess was that
something that was since day one or is
that later on when things started going
sour between you two I didn't even know
that I sucked at it but I believe that
it was after things went sour so it's it
to me anything that was said in the past
or whatever it's forgiven and I'm not
holding on to it it's just I'm using it
as an example for sure right but then I
do believe it's probably something that
was said out of spite but it still [ __ ]
with my head at the time of course cause
like when things are bad like you know
and you guys are not like coexisting in
a very happy place a lot of that stuff
that you know you said to where she said
to you it's just out of venge
being vengeful ya know and you don't
even know that you're saying it
sometimes right and it's just and I
don't think we really think about the
consequences and the repercussions of
what we say during those heated
emotional times and it tends to carry
with somebody right like for example
being told that you know you're not that
great of a kisser and it starts to
become true that there is said to you
over and over and oh yeah and I don't
even and I don't even have the
confidence to kiss another person
because I already told myself like oh
she's probably not gonna want it yeah
yeah but she wanted more and she's like
born [ __ ] man it was crazy because
yeah it's like dancing right so it's
likes with some dance partners you could
[ __ ] move in its natural and other
dance partners it just doesn't work yeah
so it's an energy thing right
starting to recognize this like okay
there's people out there that just
[ __ ] watch you for who you are and
there's other people that you have to
work for it yeah and I know this is
cliche and people say that but now I
know what that means
mmm like it just [ __ ] works and it
makes sense and it's so natural and then
you're appreciated and all these things
and I'm like oh man this is what people
were talking about do you think you
going out to Europe and kind of dating
again kind of just recharge your
batteries in terms of like the dating
scene because if it seems like you know
before dating and you know you finding
these things out it was like a lot of
the stuff that kind of mentally [ __ ]
you up in terms of your self-esteem as a
man in terms of being like feeling that
you're attractive or wanted do you think
like this your trip kind of like helped
flip that like 180 for you I kind of put
you back hell yeah dude kissing it
holding a woman and having them want you
yeah like there is no other feeling of
validation than that yeah like like [ __ ]
dude and I didn't even have to work hard
for it I was just myself mm-hmm that's
the thing is like when people say oh
just be yourself
that's what that means yeah it just
happened naturally and I'm like God dang
dude like yeah and I think I think I'm
also a little bit different too because
because my self-esteem was a certain way
I wasn't thirsty I was just hanging out
yeah without expecting anything and I
think I don't know it to me it's it's
it's kind of weird right cuz I know
there's a lot of beautiful women that
slide in the dm's comment they wanna
whatever like they want meat right what
and I and I recognize that but when it's
also in the flesh because you know at
the end of the day we're around a lot of
good-looking women but it's all work
mm-hmm
you know like there's a lot of hot
models and actors or whatever but it's
all work right and it's been
over six years or so that I've been
dating and in that feeling so what
happens to a man's psychology if you're
not a cheater
is you have one jonas syndrome hmm so
what and like you get so used to being
loyal that even after your loyal filler
you're treating kind of but more so you
forget that there's other women for
options yeah so I got so used to being
in a relationship that when I am around
beautiful women or whatever my mind's
already not thinking of them as a
potential mate oh it's just bodies it's
just people yeah right and then it work
to your advantage though right because
it allowed for you to be yourself and
just have a conversation without any
ulterior motives which allows people to
be comfortable and I think like that you
know when people think that phrase of
you know just be yourself I mean there's
certain caveats right like just be
yourself doesn't mean you go full
throttle and act all crazy around
somebody that you